welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for marvel's hawkeye on disney
plus in which clint barton teams up with
protege kate bishop in a post in game
world where captain america gets his own
musical but instead of the unforgettable
spider-man turn off the dark marvel
musical vibes a freak like me needs only
the company of a star-spangled man with
a ham molten parody
i can do this all day
forgive me i had to get that out of the
way the price of admission as i break
down this hawkeye trailer frame by frame
for all the easter eggs and interesting
details that you might have missed also
you gotta support new rockstars by
checking out our latest obsession shirt
designs inspired by what if and by
xiangxi the great protector and
newrockstarsmerge.com this video is
sponsored by our friends at heroes
journal more on them later let's get
started
this is the first christmas we've had
together
in years
i love you guys
i'm making up for some lost time
we open on new york city the empire
state building lit red and green because
tis the season folks inspired by the
2012 comic run by matt fraction and
artist david ahad this hawkeye series
evokes the christmas time action
comedies of shane black writer director
of the let the weapons series and in the
mcu iron man 3 another christmas tale
clint barton dines with his kids the
eldest son cooper his daughter lila
played by in-game co-director joe
russo's daughter ava russo with whom
clint held target practice and in-game
and his son me who's named nathaniel
pietro after natasha romanov and pietro
maximoff who saved barton's life and age
of ultron all three of these kids dusted
an endgame which is why lila now says it
has been their first christmas in years
now this would set the hawkeye series in
the first christmas after end game
december 2023 about a month after
wanavision four months before the falcon
the winter soldier six months before
spider-man far from home in about 10
months to a year before spider-man no
way home why is his timeline so
important
it's not but actually i do have a pretty
timeline intensive theory that i'll get
to later but more importantly where is
clint's wife laura barton laura colleen
clint was the first sign we got of
people returning from the blip and in
the closing montage the family seemed
pretty happily reunited we do know from
the phone call later that clint still
seems like he has some relationship with
laura enough to call her babe maybe they
just couldn't get linda carlini for this
series or maybe laura realized that all
that violent stuff that clint was up to
during the blip is not stuff she feels
comfortable being around the kids and
they might be going through a temporary
separation but i think they're still
together ultimately they attend a
broadway musical called rogers with the
black and yellow design and the star a
clear nod to the hamilton logo in this
theater is the luntfontan theater on
west 46th just down the block from the
richard rogers theater where hamilton
plays the design uses cap shield for the
o with the tagline captures the heart of
a hero and critics raving a timeless
story for a timeless hero a superpower
sensation a musical is triumphant as the
heroes it brings to life and a soaring
smashing flying fighting musical triumph
had to bring a bit of harvey in there
this brings steve rogers full circle
with his musical theater origins selling
war bonds on tour as he starts mangled
man with the plan since this series is
set before the falcon the winter soldier
the government might have sponsored this
production in order to lay the
groundwork for their whole pr strategy
to reboot the captain america brand for
john walker since they did seem to have
a similar public narrative about the
avengers victory in captain america in
the smithsonian exhibit maybe clint will
actually run into john walker at this
performance or like a spotlight will
swing over to walker in an opera box and
he has to like awkwardly wave notice
here in another shots that clint wears a
hearing aid is one of many details
pulled from fraction's comic series in
which clint suffers hearing loss among
many physical maladies as his body
begins to wear out now in the mcu clint
may have had his hearing damage during
the endgame final battle since when
thanos bombed the avengers compound he
was the only non-powered human not in a
super suit at that time of the explosion
or maybe natasha deafened him screaming
don't draw me don't draw me to draw me
i'm sorry is that too soon clint no yeah
yeah it was too soon next clip
authorities are wondering if the masked
vigilante who terrorized the city's
underworld is back
the past has caught up with me
should we be worried no no it's nothing
i'll be able for christmas so clint
flashes back to end game when he was the
ronin assassin in tokyo there are news
reports of a masked vigilante who
terrorized the city's underworld
recalling the reputation that clint
built during the blip like the scene
rhodey described in mexico the
federalists found a room full of bodies
looks like a bunch of cartel guys never
even had a chance to get their guns off
but now in these reports wearing clint's
ronin get up is kate bishop now kate
bishop was clint's mint tea in the
fraction run but she originally debuted
as one of the young avengers in 2005 an
accomplished archer and daughter of a
wealthy publisher who gets attacked in
central park becomes a vigilante and yes
this series will probably feature clint
barton training kate bishop ahead of an
mcu young avengers series with several
other young avengers characters already
cast from other mcu titles clint sends
his kids home to the farm while he stays
behind in new york you can also see some
parallels here to die hard a dude in an
unstable marriage just trying to make it
back to the family for christmas but
getting his ass kicked in the process in
this case i think clint's unfinished
business will be at first to just stop
this rogue ronin copycat but then that
sucks them into this whole conflict with
the criminal underworld of the city now
for the first time we get a hawkeye
themed marvel studios title logo tinted
indigo colors as the target rings ripple
outward andy williams holiday classic
it's the most wonderful time of the year
plays throughout this trailer it's a
song i always loved as that loud brassy
christmas is here whether you like it or
not pops seasonal alarm clock for folks
dragged into the holiday spirit which
just works really well for the chaos
clint finds himself stuck in throughout
this trailer so let's move on to it
when i wore this suit
i made a whole lot of enemies
you're a hawkeye what the hell are you
okay barton tracks down kate and unmask
sir the two of them fight these dudes in
these red tracksuits this is actually
the tracksuit draculas which is also
from the fraction run of the comics it's
a russian mafia gang known for
constantly saying bro and like many
gangs in manhattan are connected to
wilson fisk kingpin in the comics they
muscle out tenants from clint's building
and they are led by a guy named ivan in
this case i think he's a taller dude you
can see standing in the background in
the darker track suit and he stands
among them later on in the trailer when
they're all pointing guns at clint you
could add this ivan to the list of
possible ivans who could have been
natasha romanov's biological father
according to red skull at least natasha
daughter of ivan
because he knows your daddy's name i
didn't know just a reminder ivan is like
john in russia everybody's named ivan
now remember there's also that skrull in
the tracksuit who showed up in the tva
in loki as well as the skrull who
recruited monica rambo at the end of
juanavision and really as far as future
marvel titles that this series is gonna
set up it's young avengers most likely
but also secret invasion at the top of
my list because i just assumed that
according to law of averages one out of
every 10 mcu characters is probably
gonna be a scroll kate shows off her
archery by hitting a bell rope which
dings perfectly with andy williams song
collapsing the freaking bell tower
similar to how peter parker nearly let a
bell tower and venice collapse barton
takes kate home to this building that if
you look through the window that is a
pizza shop which actually might be
herman's hearty slice from the molotov
cocktail shot maybe the building where
kate now lives running up against the
russian mafia's control over the
neighborhood putting her in clint's
position for the fraction comics this
could be the pizza shop where lucky the
pizza dog gets his reputation of love
and pizza now the heroes journal is here
to help you accomplish your goals by
turning them into a quest based on goal
setting psychology and the story theory
behind some of your favorite fandoms the
heroes journal helps you discover the
story you tell about yourself and define
the quest you want to undertake they
actually just released their latest
journal the astoria magic academy the
new feature of this model is that the
art changes every single day there is a
visual story that unfolds every single
day throughout the journal
with chapter reflection pages every
seven daily pages so like as you fill
out every page you can just see how your
story is evolving it's really cool but
whether your goals involve improving
your health or taking a step forward in
your career or finally undertaking that
big creative project the hero's journal
guides you along the journey to
achieving your goal what's really cool
about the heroes journal is that it
builds a positive narrative about
productivity versus a shame-based
narrative you get to feel good about all
those tiny steps you're taking on a
daily basis the hero's journal is
available for purchase now but if you're
not ready for your quest yet you can
still check out the instruction and
first act of the journal for free on
their website just head to
heroesjournal.co
or click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars for your 10
off then there's a shot of grand central
station which just showed up in last
week's episode of what if here if you
look at the top of the scaffolding the
first responders statue that was at an
age of ultron is still there
memorializing the battle of new york
then the tracksuit mafia tries to throw
a molotov cocktail into the building but
clint freaking catches it and throws it
back at them but if you look inside of
this flat on the far left of frame there
is a poster that reads something
rhyme or ream with a fencing figure
maybe the word is scream meaning fencing
in french which could be a nod to kate's
fencing training sword fighting and
archery both being among her many combat
skills actor tony dalton will be playing
jack dukane aka swordsman on the show in
the comics swordsman was a carnival
performer and a criminal who trained
clint barton when he was young in this
show it sounds like he will be a
colleague of kate's mother eleanor
bishop played by vera farmiga who
appears later in red and evil hair yes i
think there's a good chance she will be
a villain in this series could be the
wealth that kate grew up in that now she
rebels against and some believe that
eleanor could be the longtime kate
bishop villain madame mask on the show
and in the fraction run madame sets up a
black market auction in madrapore to
auction off a security tape that would
have exposed clint killing a dictator
and one of the big bitters on it is
wilson fisk kingpin and i think they
might do a version of it in this show
because there is a shot later in this
trailer showing a high profile auction
that is held discreetly in a random wine
cellar meaning it's probably really off
the books and it gets crashed by someone
from the outside could that be kool-aid
kingpin coming through there i can't
bring it up kingpin because he has been
rumored to make his mcu debut in this
series similar to how daredevil matt
murdock has been rumored to appear in
spider-man no way home again just rumors
so far but both titles will come out
into our world concurrently no way home
is coming to theaters december 17th
right between hawkeye episodes four and
five and we may now be looking at
marvel's plan to reintroduce netflix
marvel characters into the mcu like use
hawkeye to establish new york as a city
run by fisk which would set up no way
home chronologically almost a year later
for defense attorney matt murdock to
make his appearance then barton jumps
out a 30 rockefeller center trying to
zipline using his bow but fails the
camera cuts away but in a later shot of
the ice rink the tree has now toppled
with its star on the ice so i'm guessing
clint just took the whole thing down and
then he ices his injuries using frozen
pina colada mix but in the background of
the living room is a poster reading
creature of a dark galaxy maybe a movie
fictionalizing thanos invasion the way
cap is now being turned into a narrative
with that musical and the way movies
about the blip showed up on peter
parker's airplane screen in spider-man
far from home then barton gets captured
by the tracksuit mafia and kate zip
lines in with her bow but has no better
luck than he did and crash lands right
in front of them they're even clumsy in
the same way and then the mafia rushes
in armed upon 30 rock actually late
night with seth meyer's producer mike
shoemaker tweeted that you can see his
office in this shot and how he lights it
up blue for autism awareness not really
a marvel easter egg or anything i just
think it's cool the director on this
series is rhys thomas who's a longtime
director for saturday night live late
night with seth and other broadway video
titles so yeah this 30 rock imagery is
very much his home turf then a shot of a
number from rogers the musical
everything in this frame is amazing cap
of course is front and center but above
him on the balcony level is hawkeye
black widow and iron man on either side
of them looks like chatari soldiers then
a couple service workers the waitress on
the left maybe not the deleted waitress
subplot and avengers hot dog vendor on
the right could be that vendor whose
cart was crushed by the debris in that
movie then on the lower level far far
left i'm assuming ant-man because you
can see the pimtec logo on his shirt and
then thor now a lot of people are saying
that does kind of look like chris evans
i'm not sure if they would put his
sneaky cameo in the trailer like this
but i will say this dude has the arms
for the part then a loki with an amazing
top hat crown then on the other side
with the green hoodie i'm assuming
that's hulk then two more chatario on
the other side of him but i'm not sure
about the guys on either side of cap
here but i'm guessing from the white lab
coat that could be dr abraham erskine
which then would make me think that
could be howard stark on the left
whether that is howard or just a new
york who loves new york it is played by
adam pascal broadway veteran who played
roger in rent now one of these might be
brian darcy james's character he played
king george iii and hamilton after
jonathan groff did he is the version i
saw he was amazing i could see them
casting him here for his musical theater
prowess and while i assume this scene is
depicting the battle of new york yes
there is no event in marvel history
where all of these characters were
present together like ant-man wasn't
there for that it wouldn't be the battle
of earth because loki wasn't there for
that neither was black widow but this is
just a musical and many musical closing
numbers just feature all the major
characters returning then this quick
shot of lucky the pizza dog all ready
for the holidays all now in the comics
lucky was first owned by ivan and was
named arrow but then clint saved him
took him to the vet and renamed him
lucky and notice how they make it look
like lucky's eye has been injured here
in set photos the dog's eyes look normal
so this is likely vfx because they're
not gonna put like uncomfortable makeup
on the dog just as a way to show how the
dog's eye got injured in the comics then
a couple shots where it looks like kate
in the ronin outfit and clint battling
with a bunch of larpers between this and
loki visiting the ren faire i love
marvel leaning into that subculture then
barton and kate walk up to 30 rock
dressed to the nines i'm assuming this
is all part of that same sequence that
fancy party that gets shot up that clint
is running through could actually be an
event thrown by kate's mother eleanor
and that's how they were able to get
invited and what leads to that whole ice
rink crossfire now this woman in red
light is a lock will cox as maya lopez
aka echo a fighter with photographic
memory that can echo any physical attack
similar to taskmaster she's deaf and a
member of the cheyenne nation now in the
comics her father was killed by kingpin
and in this show her father has been
cast so we might actually see that
happen and with clint's hearing loss in
the series i'm wondering if her deafness
might be a way that these two characters
connect and then this awesome street
chase taken directly from the fraction
comic except in that one clint and kate
were driving the red car that tells kate
that some of his arrows are just too
dangerous and she uses an explosive one
to light up this trusty bro moving van
probably one of the mafia's fronts a nod
of course their love of saying bro come
on bro kate says holy
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one it does make one wonder which
of clint's arrows are more dangerous
than that i guess he did fire a cluster
bomb at iron man civil war that was the
arrow that scott lang was attached to
but i am hoping that somehow clint might
have gotten yondu's yaka arrow in his
quill maybe a gift from rocket or
kraglin who i think had at last clinton
kate jumped toward the water and then
turned toward camera with their foes
ready a callback to clint's big move in
the first avengers movie and the opening
image of the fraction comic when clint
says okay this looks bad a line that i
assume will come up in this series and
yeah it's pretty cool to see both
hawkeyes do the move together and then
the title with the arrow flying into the
a to form a target but the a is only
circular target of bull because it's
lower case which is cool because it's
taken directly from the fraction series
which in that case reflected the fun
stylistic choice of those comics to
depict clint's inner monologue all in
lower case well i guess not all in
lowercase but just not all in uppercase
as opposed to the all caps that you
would normally see characters speaking
in dialogue in i'm very excited for this
series i think it's gonna be a fun thing
to enjoy the holidays with of course
we'll be doing an episode by episode
breakdowns and after shows of this so be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow us on all social media you can
follow me personally on instagram and
twitter at eavos again support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com thanks
for watching see you next time bye
[Music]
you